nadège il ya une heure quand on vous
avait le cortège n'était pas parti est
ce que cette fois ci il est parti oui le
cortège est bel et bien parti à grégory
est long on est devant l'assemblée
nationale assemblée nationale qui a été
tué par les manifestants et si puisque
c'est là que le projet de loi bioéthique
a été approuvé en première lecture à
l'assemblée nationale ce projet de loi
de bioéthique il doit aussi être examiné
à partir de mardi au sénat alors ce
projet de loi bioéthique il prévoit
comme vous l'avez dire la pma pour
toutes les femmes la procréation
médicalement assistée et c'est l'un des
points qui fait polémique ici puisqu'il
selon d'après plusieurs manifestants et
bien le rôle du père devrait disparaître
la famille la structure familiale
pourrait être abîmée par ce projet de
loi donc je suis avec france françois
xavier à bellamy euro députés les
républicains pourquoi bonjour et
pourquoi est ce que vous faites partie
de cette manifestation aujourd'hui bien
je suis venu pour témoigner comme un élu
mais aussi comme un français tout
simplement de l'importance de ce sujet
je crois que nous sommes vraiment à un
point de bifurcation majeur pour notre
avenir celui qui décidera du statut de
la médecine et de la condition humaine
en réalité la pma ouverte à toutes les
femmes et aux femmes seules
c'est évidemment une manière de
transformer le rapport au geste médical
qui n'est plus là pour réparer une
maladie comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
mais qui devient l'occasion d'obtenir ce
que la condition humaine ne nous donne
jamais par elle-même et au moment où
nous allons vers des débats fondamentaux
sur le transhumanisme et l'homme
augmenté
je crois que nous sommes ici vraiment à
un carrefour on a découvert avec la
prise de conscience écologique que notre
désir de toute puissance dans le rapport
à la nature avait pu faire des
catastrophes que nous ne savons pas
réparé je crois qu'il est temps d'avoir
la sagesse nécessaire pour se
réconcilier avec la nature dans ce
qu'elle a de limites mais dans ce cas là
aussi de fécondité lorsqu'il s'agit de
nos propres corps lors le le texte
devrait être examiné par le sénat à
partir de mardi
est-ce que mécénat qui est
majoritairement de droite mais pourtant
le texte devrait être approuvé enfin
qu'est ce que vous en pensez à ce que
vous croyez encore que le sénat puisse
faire marche arrière
le travail législatif suit son cours il
sera encore long puisque après l'examen
par le sénat il y aura de nouveau un
examen à l'assemblée nationale nous nous
faisons d'une certaine façon notre notre
travail de citoyen en venant témoigner
les parlementaires français doivent
faire leur propre travail de législateur
droite ce qui est le plus important et
c'est le message que on voudrait
partager que je voudrais partager ici je
crois que le plus important c'est que
chaque élu fasse son choix en conscience
évidemment les avis peuvent être
partagées je respecte le fait que chacun
puisse prendre sa décision bien sûr mais
ce qui est très important c'est de ne
pas se laisser intimider
denis par les injonctions que l'on peut
parfois suivirent aujourd'hui pour aller
dans le sens du vent pour suivre le sens
du progrès ni non plus par l'idée que
l'histoire est écrite d'avancé
en réalité nous sommes responsables de
ce que nous faisons de notre propre
destin
mais je crois que ce qui se joue ici est
vraiment fondamental est suffisamment
pour que chacun puisse y réfléchir
librement
merci beaucoup françois xavier à bellamy
à député européen à l'est républicain
donc vous l'avez entendu pour ce député
européen cette loi bioéthique devrait
porter un coup à la médecine dégradées
et le rôle de la médecine donc aux
ballades manifestation qui poursuit son
cours un cortège qui est est bien passé
je le disais devant l'assemblée
nationale où le projet a été approuvé en
première lecture un texte qui devrait
être examiné à partir de mardi au sénat
avant de revenir à l'assemblée nationale
plus tard